foreign
[Music]
there are 345 million people currently
facing high levels of food insecurity
who need urgent assistance and 24
million of them are already on the brink
of famine so you can imagine an
additional shock to that situation can
cause Untold numbers of people to tip
over the edge into the abyss of hunger
thank you
[Music]
as we all remember the prices spiked
last year after the conflict started a
basic food things like wheat and corn
and caused a lot of volatility in the
market and rampant inflation and we fear
that those types of events will occur
again in the absence of this deal
[Music]
foreign
this will be a huge shock to the global
system and hit those least able to cope
on living on the edge of hunger our
hardest
[Music]